in many shown in anime we see the
journey of a young and boastful
character learning how to control their
abilities and fighting off evils and
injustice in the world however alongside
this stable main character we often see
a wise old mental character too besides
being old and gray these old men are
anything but fragile and weak they're
some of the toughest and strongest
characters in their universe so in this
list we're counting down the top 10 old
badasses from anime let's get to it
we start off this list with none other
than makarov from fairy tale the lovable
guild master of fairy tale has to be
powerful in order to be respected and at
times feared by his fellow guild members
makarov's definitely powerful being one
of the 10 wizards saying he's also
capable of creating his own spells such
as fairy law a spell that's known to
eliminate anyone and everyone that the
user sees as a danger to the caster and
his allies makarov's also a master of a
multitude of magics ranging from his
giant magic to fairy magic and others
including wind and fire magic this shows
how versatile and fluent he is in
learning all sorts of abilities in the
magical world he resides in
[Music]
next at number nine we have walter from
helsing ultimate in his youth walter was
not only known to storm occupied areas
in poland during the second world war
but also helping to put a stop to the
creation of vampire armies however
walter's youth wasn't the only period in
his life which he was present in all
sorts of monumental events after honing
his skills for years walter earned the
nickname angel of death for the ways he
could kill someone even in his 60s he
could still rip through loads of
vampires as if he was a 20-something
walter despite taking up the role of a
butler later in life was still capable
of taking out hordes of the undead and
did so without even making it look like
he was struggling
okay
coming in at number seven is sarutobi
from naruto this is the third hokage of
the naruto series he was made to be the
hokage by the second one at an early age
and despite his powers and abilities
deteriorating greatly with his age the
old man was still able to hold off
numerous powerful enemies with little to
no help at all sarutobi's ninjutsu is
immensely powerful as well having been
seen using all five basic nature
transformations as well as creating
several techniques on his own now when
facing new techniques he's able to
understand and break them down to the
point of mastering or creating a better
version for himself sarutobi's truly
worthy of the title of hokage and from
his mere feats and skills alone it's
clear that anyone who challenges him
must be stupidly brave or bravely stupid
or she
is here at number six like all arjin
sato is immortal he won't die under any
circumstances whatsoever such as being
crushed decapitated or even malnourished
with not only the abilities of an arjun
sato also has extensive military
training having served in an elite
operation for the us marine corps during
the vietnam war he's also a master
manipulator having tricked and allowed k
nagai to trust him before showing his
true intentions he's a man who separates
his emotions from his work a trait that
helps him perform ruthless crimes in the
underworld sato someone you don't want
to be on the bad side of and someone who
you shouldn't trust under any
circumstance as you can never be sure of
what his true motives really are
[Music]
yeah
scarlett danny
while gintama is known most of the time
to be a humorous anime there are times
when it brings us to the edge of our
seats with hosum playing the role of the
main antagonist in the yoshiwara in
flames arc it was clear that his older
character wasn't going to be as
lighthearted and funny as the usual
bunch rather hosun was described as a
bloodthirsty tyrant who ruled with an
iron fist even going so far as to show
him cutting the tendons of hinoa's feet
to make sure she couldn't run away one
of his many examples of his cruelty his
personality wasn't the only thing to be
feared though as wholesome produced a
multitude of superhuman traits such as
speed strength and durability a
dangerous man with dangerous morals
making for a thrilling arc in the
guintama series
next is king bradley from full metal
alchemist not only is bradley the
original fuhrer of amestres but the
final and one of the strongest
homunculus created by father he has an
inhumane skill in swordsmanship and
hand-to-hand combat now bradley's a
master of manipulation putting on a
front of being a wise old gentleman
while under the surface he's an
anger-fueled man wanting nothing more
than to make father's wishes come true
like the other homunculus bradley is
known to have inhumane speed durability
stamina and his ultimate eye this grants
him extra sensory vision and
precognition to events making him quite
the hard foe in a battle because he's
not only hard to strike but it's hard to
get an upper hand against him too
[Music]
like many other older gentlemen on this
list was abnormally gifted in his youth
having a great skill set in mastering
nen to being placed as the head of the
exam board and the 12th chairman of the
hunter association even with a teasing
and calm personality angering this old
man would be the greatest mistake anyone
could make he claimed the title of the
most powerful menus of 50 years prior to
the series he has control over at least
three men categories okay firstly his
natural category enhancement which in
conjunction with his astounding martial
arts skills and strong body make him a
dreadful malay fighter then a mission
which activates his strongest attack and
finally he employs manipulation to make
the nen statue mimic his movements it's
no wonder why this old man has played so
highly on our list with the skills he
possesses
[Music]
kitty
and finally at number one we have none
other than whitebeard from one piece
edward newgate more commonly known as
whitebeard was at one point known as the
strongest man in the world and the one
who came the closest to one piece he was
known to be one of the few men in the
world who could ever match the late
pirate king goldie roger in a fight
whitebeard ate the quake quake fruit a
paramecia type devil fruit that made him
a quake man and which was considered the
strongest devil fruit within the
paramecia class according to sengoku
whitebeard had the power to destroy the
world truly someone you wouldn't want to
upset seeing as even death had a hard
time taking this old man down
and with that we finish off our list of
old badasses you clearly don't want to
challenge but which old fighting geezer
is your favorite let us know in the
comments below thank you so much for
watching this video be sure to leave a
like subscribe for more great anime
content until next time remember that
with age always comes more the mere
wisdom
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]